oops but late stardom yeah welcome to
this video playing I am say do now we've
got some the carers variation here in
the English oh that's that's uncommon
it's interesting the interesting moment
I can go III or I can move the move it
I'm not sure really about all this cause
my development is pretty good I could
get three now is he going for a four a
five or something that's possible mmm
and I can go d3 up Galgo d3m its end is
somewhat shaky
okay so couple of options Bishop e3
maybe just be should be three yeah I can
also take this have the same all looks
pretty good
you
and guess you're wondering there's a
church nearby yeah some where's he going
with the Queen it doesn't have many
great options may be back welcome Queen
d8 is extremely poor if you have to play
it yeah i mean just doesn't feel like a
particularly great situation to be in so
here couple of interesting things even
Queen d4 as a good move I think
attacking g7 and attacking the bishop he
has to take then give me the bishop Pam
yeah let's do it i mean not spend too
much time in check
yeah roop t1 is interesting directly
putting pressure on this so nice is six
and maybe can just take on d5 grab a
pawn okay gives me that point maybe if
maybe I ok i see no I can take c3 at the
end oh I don't didn't see that didn't
see you night ok I think I start the
guts to go for it I scopus should be 69
hmm now my development is not that great
yeah now that wasn't good I didn't play
that well
it's called active pieces now no hair I
completely miss miss evaluated um miss
evaluated knight c6 I didn't see that c3
was hanging really an irryan issue here
okay so Jeff cannot even Castle him i
was thinking i can take on b7 but that's
probably not the case Ruby age okay I
can maybe do it then we should be 4i
can't actually do that
so not relative okay ff5 should see two
it's a little bit shaky so I'm gonna
shake him I think you can just go 85
maybe has something better that I don't
see that's possible bit awesome f5 plays
soft f5 Bishop c2m right before couple
of things hanging on my end well I
didn't really have an alternative I
think what do I play against night
before yeah maybe the bishop again to a
four or something should a phone
and looks should be ok yeah I just
wonder that I can castle him yeah mm
root g1s bishop em lets you before I
shouldn't you shouldn't now that let's
do this threaten a book the one now and
this is a bit annoying here because if
he goes Bishop b4 I might take a go f3
stuff like that it's a little bit
uncoordinated okay at no time black
resigned under the p-side that i miss
played that outside of the opening i
think the position here must be very
good
must be very good takes yeah maybe
Bishop g2 assign the spell oh ok so
Bishop g2 is probably been having I'm
better developed so this is this is
rather nice and yeah that isn't all that
grade because he has this this strong
move here 96 engine thinks it's equal
here I I was kind of skeptical about
this it felt like killing his active
pieces our problem the engine still
gives all gives it uses equal all the
way so it wasn't all that terrible and
playing precisely it seems I'm playing
all the engine moves Castle is a bit of
a fancy movement you really can do that
chasm or move 24 when the rook is
attacked c5 should be 3 is even better
according to the comp not quite sure why
okay neither the roof is covered that
that could be a point but still this
looks pretty and fine here it's losing a
threatening move d file and bishops is
six ok I was a tough game thanks for
watching